nous sommes dans les carrières de
tuffeau sur les bords du cher ces sites
majestueux jean-philippe tous les
connaît bien cela fait des années qu'ils
les arpente avec ses amis du club spéléo
de touraine un environnement qu'il adore
mais moi je me sens vraiment
reposé apaisé j'ai vraiment mon cerveau
il se met en mode
vraiment zen
ce qui me plaît c'est assez vraiment le
côté science de d'aller là où l'eau
circule creuse
formule des réseaux qu'on n'imagine pas
quand on est à l'extérieur ça c'est
vraiment le côté on va dire magique
féerique dans quelques semaines le
spéléologue va vivre une aventure peu
commune avec l'un de ses amis il va
s'enfermer pendant 60 jours dans la
grotte naturelle de trabuc dans le gard
60 jours pour vivre dans des conditions
extrêmes d'isolement pour réussir cette
expérience il faut une parfaite hygiène
de vie on a prévu de se lever à 7h du
matin tous les jours on aura une montre
en or à 10 ordinateurs dans quoi on aura
à vivre une journée qui sera bien
cadencée une journée rythmée par les
différentes activités d'observation et
de recherche scientifique
mais l'objet de ce séjour c'est surtout
une étude universitaire sur leurs
propres comportements psychologiques
liés à l'enfermement alors dans les
annales à genève cardio pompe gainage le
spéléologue soigne sa préparation
physique il le sait c'est l'une des clés
pour réussir son expérience au dojo de
bléré y pratique le taïso une discipline
japonaise
pour nous prépare physiquement donc avec
le taïso ça nous permet de travailler
les muscles des cuisses parce qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on est des bons appuis
l'equilibre chercher l'équilibré en fait
le travail du taï so c'est aussi ça et
puis c'est aussi travailler donc le haut
du corps pour s'agripper donc comme si
on faisait des escalades mais là sur des
blocs qui sont plus ou moins stable sur
des terrains qui sont vraiment très
accidenté une activité que les deux
spéléologues vont répéter pendant toute
la durée de l'opération pour entretenir
corps et mentale
[Musique]
derniers préparatifs
l'essentiel du matériel est déjà sur
place mais il reste encore le problème
des vêtements que l'on doit protéger de
l'atmosphère si humide de la grotte je
suis en train de faire le vide dans un
sac l'internet de stocker mes vêtements
autres soins du corps mais aussi
nourriture de l'esprit là encore c'est
davanture dont il s'agit et j'ai prévu
d'apporter donc des des livres fait par
des aventuriers aussi donc comme eric
tabarly donc le célèbre navigateur il ne
reste plus que quelques jours avant le
début de cette aventure l' isolement
sera totale sans aucune relation avec
l'extérieur nous serons situés ici
précisément soit à peu près entre 700 et
800 mètres de l'entrée naturel et
environ 150 mètres de profondeur la
descente dans la salle du kao est prévue
le lundi 29 novembre lille deux
spéléologues ressortiront bien après les
fêtes le jeudi 27 janvier
[Applaudissements]